on va prendre un exemple et vous allez
nous expliquer c'est vous qui avez fait
la publicité pour une montre et vous
fait croire que vous utilisez cette
montre alors qu'en fait
j'avais porté mais qu'est ce que vous en
voulez pas aujourd'hui en tout cas non
mais qu'est ce que vous en savez que je
la porte pas voulu porter qu'est ce que
vous en oui j'en dis j'ai déjà porté
bien sûr la moins connectée gelé déjà
porté bien sûr une tendinite au bras
donc j'ai déjà porté
oui elle est revenue sur cette histoire
de tendinite au bras elle a donné des
explications mais entre temps ça a été
une énorme rigolade puisque tout le
monde a tweeté là dessus et des tweets
incroyable pôle emploi en fait c'est
très content du pôle emploi même à 4
tandis que certains sont passibles en
effet
[Applaudissements]
les cherry à un autre ça je vous jure
que c'est pas une bonne douche olive
vraiment le 6 octobre un atelier pour la
tendinite c'est par ici regardez non il
n'aurait tout le monde l'a fait merci
voilà ton tiny qu'ils ont fait yatim
d'air france sort ici j'ai pas swype à
droite j'ai une tendinite au bras
[Applaudissements]
il ya même le buffalo grise c'est vrai
mais fallo keita vous retrouverez
bientôt drac
[Applaudissements]
federer
ne fait pas débat il ya le crédit
agricole mutuel qu'à regarder pas besoin
du teasing tendinite pas besoin
d'utiliser ses doigts votre village
suivie à vous identifiez vous identité
sur votre appli voilà c'est vraiment le
fait d agri cole c'est pas une batterie
c'est fou il ya même une vraie vidéo
france des objets une tendinite ça va
être chaud pour la sortir maintenant
regarder voilà
alors il parlait de la saison passée
c'est un carrefour carrefour carrefour
la fête où il a supprimé après je prends
aussi comme magali berda et mila jasmin
vous êtes tous seraient bientôt à leur
recherche d'un emploi on a plein
d'offres sur
[Applaudissements]
c'est drôle alors elle s'explique et
magali et regardez
vous ai dit ça parce qu'il me dit vous
êtes vous n'avez pas vous la mettez pas
la manger lime et déjà vous êtes avec
moi 24 heures sur 24 pour savoir que
j'ai plusieurs montres des fois je mets
l'une des fois je mets l'autre chacun
est libre de faire ce qu'il veut et
ensuite j'ai voulu dire j'ai une
tendinite au bras est le fait de porter
une montre connectés ça m'aide en fait
c'est à dire que les gens ils ont
compris elle met pas une montre parce
que elle a une tendinite alors c'était
pas ça s'est joué à dire que les montres
connecter les gens pour des tendinites
ça nous aide a pas apporté le téléphone
est un pas avoir la main tout le temps
voilà c'était dans ce sens elle je
voulais dire alors pardon si j'ai pas
été très fier mais bien évidemment c'est
parce que j'ai une tendinite que je
porte pas de montre
ce soir
[Applaudissements]
sa femme et ses non moins bien sûr il ya
quelques jeunes ici ça regardez elle est
infiniment réjouit et moi je pense
qu'elle a complètement réussi sont les
bien sûr c'est à dire qu'on parle je ne
connais pas cette saison mais ça me
rappelle un épisode de halo tapas de
chaque fois ça lui a pas porté malheur
la partie dite et grâce à ce truc là
elle elle s'en explique avec le sourire
au début de la vidéo et ça explique bien
ce que ça veut dire à mon sens je suis
je ne connais pas le sait pas qui c'est
mais en tout cas on parle d'elle voilà à
la candélie on est con on est dans ce
monde la
ccsa croit en tout cas ça a été assez
largement rollier